yeah the the Intel brief we got about 30
days before we left said you're going to
the safest place in Iraq in April 2004
one year after the fall of Saddam
Hussein Iraq was controlled by a us-led
transitional government this period
marked a relative low in violence in the
war the soldiers stationed at Camp War
Eagle expected an uneventful deployment
we deployed you know we knew that there
had been a lot of enemy activity in Sadr
City up to that point you know that I
think there's general knowledge that you
know there had been a shot fired in over
six months the division was tasked with
peacekeeping and supporting local
rebuilding efforts in a part of Baghdad
known as Sadr City initially what we
thought we were going to do is go over
there and provide security to
contractors who are going to come in and
repair damaged sewage system and repair
the damaged fresh water system prepare
the electrical systems all of the things
that have deteriorated since the first
Gulf War because the bombing that we did
there and because neglect by some of the
same government before we find the topic
that was the mission that we thought we
were going to do Sadr City was
increasingly controlled by muqtada
al-sadr an influential religious
activists and vocal opponent of foreign
occupation in Iraq on March 28th u.s.
coalition forces ordered the closure of
el satyrs newspaper which escalated the
tensions that would lead to violence
when the ambush started we were actually
headed back in we had been out escorting
the sewage trucks throughout the day as
we moved in move down that road you know
a couple rounds fired and we stopped to
look from where it was and that's when
it within a few minutes we knew exactly
what was going on we were involved in a
closed ambush
[Music]
[Music]